details on a northeast valley murder  that happened early this morning metro  police say this took place at an  apartment complex near lake mead and  nellis just after 4. officers say a man  in his 20's was shot and killed on a  basketball court  right now the information we have is  extremely limited but what we do know is  that the victim was inside the apartment  camp outside in the apartment complex  with his several of his friends and at  some point in time he got up and walked  away towards the basketball court area  when he got  outside of view of any of his friends  and that short time later several  gunshots were heard  right now metro police are looking for  the people involved as you heard details  pretty limited if you have any  information on what happened call metro  police or crime stoppers  385-5555 you can remain anonymous